so what we would be trying is there are
some obviously this is a huge leap and
has helped us in finding some of the
those structures where we have the
information before but uh where there is
no information when where there is no
experimental structures available and if
there's a unique uh unique mode for
protein that is something that is still
not answered answered by the AI based
models so some of the limitations that
would be answered through experimental
techniques and we have those techniques
which are evolving also at the same pace
and with the new structures and
everything I think this is going to be
getting better and better uh only
another the last data base today that we
are discussing about is the
is another now we are discussing from
Discovery now to chemistry uh so
chemistry kme MBL is a manually curated
database so bioactic bioactive molecules
that has drug-like properties uh it
brings together chemistry uh bioactivity
genomic data as well to Aid the
translation of genetic information into
these effective new drugs so chemi MBL
is a database again which has two two
dimensional structures calculated
properties such as log P molecular
weight and then Lipinski parameters and
abstracted by activities such as binding
constant pharmacology at my data so this
data is abstracted and curated uh from
either Publications like primary
scientific literature and covers
fractions of these uh and helps us in
you know structure activity
relationships and discovery of modern
drugs so as we have been discussing and
discussed so many uh these not so many
at least four or five of these databases
uh it'll be really great if you can uh
maybe browse uh some of them as we will
be also sharing with you the links and
all uh after the session so please after
the between the sessions please go
through this and have the questions that
you can ask us related to them now we
will be moving towards the case study
and we discussed about coronavirus and
the SAS Cove too so we'll take our scope
2 as a case study so that's uh the
entire all of the SAS group 2 pandemic
has also shown a light on many diverse
contribution of this in Silicon
structural biology work so initially
structure prediction work uh we used to
you we had used in that time modelers
ice eye tester and Alpha fold and this
deep mind uh all of that but one of the
key challenges now is to understand that
you heard of the way uh some of these
proteins replicate and the the way they
they create these mutations and there
are several copies so understanding the
the very the mutations actually this in
mutation scan
disrupt or become more lethal so we have
a case study plan on that not in the
first session obviously towards the uh
towards uh the second or third session
where we will be able to look look at
the specific types of these variants and
the structures because many of the
structures have now reported and at a
very good resolution so we can do that
case study where we can compare the
variations that you could see in
different types of these variants where
there are different mutations at
different locations so that is the case
study that we have planned but in
addition like the uh if you look at the
structures all of this started with the
spike protein and which is at the
surface of the coronavirus so uh these
bikes and giving them their distinctive
Crown like appearance in electron
micrographs that's the reason they are
called the they are called Spike so the
spike initiation initiates the process
of infection and then binding to The
receptors and then fusing with the cell
membrane to release the viral genome
inside and many of you might be our
virologist and have a better
understanding but from a structural
point of view what I'm trying to
describe here is that many other
enveloped viruses such as similar to
spike proteins uh to use the similar
mechanism to infect cells that has been
known so for example influenza and the
enveloped glycoproteins of hiv-1 and
Ebola as well so this uh
the spike protein is com is composed of
three identical genes so we are talking
about three chains a b and c chains and
uh and then together they form a complex
with a small domain inside the virus a
membrane spanning segment and a large
electrodomain that extends the spike
protein in two different types of like
it it is very flexible to move in that
manner so in this in this um in this
slide we I'm trying to explain the same
thing that when you look at and look at
these structures and recent structures
have revealed that the spike of SARS
scope 2 and sasco are kind of flexible
so in this in this structures the
receptor binding domains are seen in
different conformation now uh about
conformation is again one of the
limitation with the same protein you
will find different conformations so how
do you understand that what would be the
best confirmation to Target or what is
the actual or the average confirmation
and all of that so those are some of the
questions that could be answered when
you go through and learn from different
aspects about uh molecular Dynamic
simulations averaging structures and
understanding the movement but actually
these different conformations actually
helped us a lot with all of this the
extended confirmation is needed to bind
the receptor and
and um
and the flexibility is a great Advantage
actually to the virus because the
researchers hypothesized that the
research
variants are violent because the
receptor binding documents are
particularly flexible uh where as the
more widespread coronaviruses that
causes the common cold uh which are less
flexible so these are some of the
examples that we should be able to take
a look at and uh let's do that in the
context of
visualization so this last uh last part
of the session is doing some Hands-On
using molecular visualization so that's
as we have shared uh that with you so
6m17 and 6V SB are the four digit later
code that are uh that you can find on
pdb so let's click on some of these
links and open this in a browser and let
me know if you can if you can see my
browser or not uh so this is a link that
where we have opened a PDP file and then
in the context of visualization we are
going to use pymol so Pi mall is a
strong molecular visualization software
and in this slide you will be able to
see that I have put together a lot of
links from uh like how you can install
binomol so can you tell me like is it
installed in your system any of you like
uh do you know like have you installed
pie model ever or is it like uh
something that uh that you you can do
so
all right so many of you are saying yes
you have you have it installed and uh
for those who haven't who haven't or
hasn't uh I'll share this uh these links
in the chat perhaps that would be a
quicker way we will be sharing this uh
in an email but uh
but let me share all these links
foreign
[Music]
is a propriety software by Schrodinger
but again there are academic versions
educational versions available they are
little tricky to install but you'll find
one of them in the link so if you don't
have the full version or if you have the
demo version and if you use it for
academic uh purposes you can have the
full version and all the capabilities uh
exploring some of these links and I
think that we will not do in the session
but if you have issues please feel free
to write that in the chat group and we
will be able to help you now uh if you
have installed it the next step is to
use it and before using it let's
understand a little bit about the
interface of pymon
so the interface before understanding
about the interface it would be good to
understand that
what are the basics like how do we
visualize files and what is there in the
pdb file so uh can you tell me like do
you know what is uh what is there in a
pdb file how this coordinates are are
stored or do you have any idea like
about the
um extra crystallography and all those
methods that generates these
experimental files because what I want
to to describe discuss next is this text
file that we get from the experiments
like x-ray diffraction extra
crystallography or other techniques so
this is the file this is a text file so
when you're downloading uh uh from pdb
you kind of download a text file and
then you open it up on a in a software
that kind of projects these coordinates
in a three-dimensional space does that
make sense to all of you
all right
um so that's the whole idea that from uh
from a text file the software generates
the coordinates and uh and put it in a
three-dimensional space and I'm
discussing this uh because it's
important to understand and and if you
understand this you will be able to
actually do some modifications on your
own just through the structural
visualization so what we want to
understand in this image that is on the
on the left hand side of the screen
is uh the pdb file yeah we can do it uh
so let's do this let's do this
practically I'll stop uh the uh I'll go
we'll go to that website and let's let's
do this there so on the in the context
of uh this file and this is uh uh a
structure that I've been describing in
the presentation it's a membrane protein
and it's a viral protein and uh this is
uh there's this information that this is
generated through cryoem structure
cryo-em technology and this is the
resolution now uh there are other
information there is associated
publication published in science so you
can check the article here and
understand more about it that would be
the best way to understand about the
structure and then there are different
information so this is the complete a
chain and and d and c chain so we have
the sequences six six fifty four
amino acid long and this is one of the
visuals of the structure and then going
down you will find more information
about different clusters and then you
can zoom in and look at these individual
residues compare these different uh
sequence clusters which are similar to
this protein and then the second
molecule so they this is like not just
one molecule there are two molecules so
Angiotensin covering enzyme two so a A2
receptor is also there so you will be
able to see the protein protein complex
in this molecule now similarly there is
a third molecule the spike protein S1 so
this information is right here like the
number of molecules that are that are
there in the three-dimensional structure
co-crystallized there are so many poker
slide structures some of them are uh
some of them are part of the
experimental structure some of them are
uh artificial artifacts from the chem
from the solution so you have to
understand that which are the important
part and which are not and these sort of
information is available right here
that's the way to read through this
information here that once you go to
this page read about this information
get that understanding and there are
here tabs also so three 3D View and then
annotation so we can go through all of
this this will take a while but uh let's
uh let's download this structure first
and then we will do a visualization uh
on Primal and the next time then when we
meet uh we will be able to maybe discuss
all of this and answer the questions
that you haven't read you'll be able to
ask those questions so you will see that
there are different ways that you can
directly visualize right here in the on
the browser so you don't even need to
have Primal for that pie mall is for
those uh maybe where you're predicting
and you're modifying so it's great to
have Primal capabilities generate high
resolution structures but here also
these capabilities are there you can
look at active sites you can look at
different sites you can click and
understand the interaction also which is
a great interface that pdb is now
providing within this uh within this
portal so I I wish that I hope that you
all are going to utilize some of these
links and I'll put it in the chat
especially this one that we are looking
at so that you all can look at it and we
can maybe do it together
so now let's download this structure so
while downloading these files
you'll find different file formats that
are there now pdb format uh there is uh
this mmcif format so we we uh we can
discuss about these formats but let's
look at some of the uh one of these
formats so I have downloaded this file
and I can open it in a in a text editor
so let me open this file
in a text editor
so you can use notepad notepad plus plus
wordpad any of these text editors to
open a pdb file that you have downloaded
now so using the link as you saw that I
easily downloaded that file and this is
how it looks like this is the structure
file this is the maybe a receptor file
this is how it looks it has a lot of
remarks from the top towards going
towards the end and these remarks are
not read by the software but they
explained they explain the
characteristics of this molecule or the
structural factors and some of the
chains some of the some of the
interactions as well as these sort of
information so there's a lot of
information this this gives just to tell
you in in a in a nutshell so header
title author records provide information
about the researchers who Define the
structure numerous types of records that
have available to provide other type of
information remark record provides you
know contains a free form annotation and
then seek seek that sequence rest
records gives the sequence of these
three peptide chains like ABCD and all
atom records now what is important here
is the atom records from here this is
the important section this is the actual
file this is the actual structural file
so this is uh atom this this atom uh
describes the coordinate of the atom
that is the part of the protein for
example the first atom line describes
the alpha and atom so this is the
nitrogen at the alpha position of the of
the first residue of the peptide chain a
I hope that this is kind of clear when
we will look at it in a
three-dimensional three-dimensional
visualization as well but uh that is how
it is so it is a valine
and the residue is valine and that the
first three floating points this is x y
z this is x coordinate this is y
coordinate that's this is z coordinate
so x y z will be uh will be transposed
or will be plotted in a
three-dimensional software called Primal
now um I think this is clear and this is
kind of I explained it in much more
depth the next three columns are
occupancy temperature factor and the
element name respectively then we you
will find towards the towards the end
these there are different chains like
I'm scrolling and I hope all of you are
able to see this so this is a chain as
as we know that this is a big protein
then there is B chain you see that a has
changed to B now now this is B chain so
another subunit and then there will be
other chains also each chain
and C chain as we were reading the
molecule there D chain and then after
that so I just wanted to show
heteroatoms these are the heteroatoms
now the ligands are usually heteroatoms
so here you will find these nag which is
like a crystallized I think these nags
are present and these are sorry not
crystallized like there are some
conditions for this in the solution and
then they are there and then there is
one Auto molecule and there is zinc also
so here towards the end you will find
zinc water molecules and all of that so
each chain had some water molecules that
have been traced and put together here
so this is how you read the pdb file now
you can manually actually extract some
of this information and paste it in a
new file and create dot pdb so you can
simply like if you want to extract the F
uh like the
F Gene you just got it like properly and
paste it in a same format and save it
like and rename it like fchain.pdb so
that way you can manipulate this pdb
file you can take some of the segments
and open it and do those exercises and
those will be the assignments for the
the for today's session to manipulate my
pdb file and to do this I do this on
your own
now uh the next thing we are going to
try is pi mall now I have installed the
eyeball on my system now I'll open
primol
by this command by mall
and this uh this uh app
Ampersand sign is actually a signed that
lets me let me
um use the use the
console now that's not important so yeah
Primal that is what we would be
interested in so we have Open PI mall
and we have downloaded a structure now
let's open that structure in pie mall
and let's look at it uh and understand
what are the different ways we can
visualize it so now I have opened it in
pi mall and uh I am rotating it using my
key mouse pad tracking pad now let's
let's
uh yeah I think it's visible to all of
you now here there are a few commands
ashlc so a stands for action
and there are two tabs here all and uh
this one so you can actually load
multiple structures and in the next
session we will be discussing about
structural alignment structural
comparison and there is a workshop also
coming up on Alpha fold and doing all of
this so I hope that as many of you would
join the program will be coming and
participating on all of those events now
looking at the structure now you can
zoom in as much as you want and you can
dive and look into each molecule so here
I have highlighted just I'll just
selected clicked here and there's one uh
one atom which you just selected now you
can see that there are dots but it is
not showing in the presentation because
the presentation that we are looking at
is the cartoon presentation now there
are different types of presentations
visualize visual representations that we
will be looking at that we'll be
exploring but this the cartoon
presentation now to look at the side
chain you need a stick presentation this
is a stick presentation so this is the
nag molecule which is plotted all all
over here which is which is you can see
all over the place Niagara molecule but
I've I have clicked on a amino acid
which has a ring as it seems now I want
to see what is this amino acid so what I
will do I'll go to the select because
I've selected it there's a new tab that
has come up which says scle which is
Select this is selected now whatever
I'll do will change will make change to
only this area so this is the select and
I'll do what I'll try to show stick
as I was telling you this could be seen
in a stick representation now you can
see it's a stick representation and you
can look at the residue you can change
take a look at the residue now this is
important in the context that if you
want to know about that if there is a
mutation and you have figured out that
you know that there is this mutation so
you want to see what is the effect of
the mutation and you can check out that
by looking at the residue and then then
selecting that residue like it is
selected and in action I'll use this
function called modify around 4 angstrom
so I wanted to see that where this
residue is interacting with is is it
interacting with any other uh other
inter arm intramolecular interactions
within the protein so let's look at that
because if we want to change this if we
want to mutate it obviously obviously
some of these interactions would be lost
so so as I did that what I did is that I
went in action modify around four
angstrom so I checked what are the
interaction around four angstrom now I
have other residues also getting
highlighted or you know there are these
selections selection has expanded to
other molecules which means that there
are other molecules that are there
interacting now I can also manipulate
this structure and mutate it
this is what let's take a look at what
is this what is this uh side chain so to
name it there is this um there is this
uh tab that says label so this is label
here you can also written action is
written show is written hide is written
so you can show something you can hide
the same thing this is label it's
written and then there is color you can
change the color to different colors of
your liking or to highlight it basically
now I have selected this now I want to
mutate it but before that I need to know
which atom is it but this is tyrosine
you know this is a styrosine because you
can see here when I selected this
console is also getting updated and uh
it's it's telling me that this is a
beach in tyrosine at 641 position but we
can label it and she see it in here so
we label it it's it's showing that now
in the screen you can see search showing
tyr 641 now I want to change the status
into alanine how would I do that how can
I do that in pie Mall itself so there is
this plug-in uh wizard there is this
Mutual Genesis that you can do here
right and write it in here
right it comes up here now I have
selected this one and uh Mike I want to
change this mutation I want to bring a
mutation in the structure by changing
tyrosine to another name now what what
do I want to change it into alanin so
I'll put ala ala and I'll apply so I've
changed mutate to alanin and these are
some of the
um other other options that I can change
so I'll apply
it's asking you to pick a residue so
that's bigger residue
all right
so let's try this again
it's asking me to select a rotama
okay so I think there is a library file
for rotomas that we have to put in here
but there is this mutation I think this
now has changed into alanin so the side
chain has gone but I think with the
rotama library it will uh it will be
like uh give us probabilities of this
mutation so now this mutation is changed
into alanin so this is one of the way I
was just showing all of you to work on
these protein structures and do some
manipulation using Primal now what we
did is that we downloaded a structure
and we played around with it and we
learned about some of these things uh
now uh for the assignment uh for the
students or participants of the program
we'll be sharing some of these protein
IDs and ask you to prepare a report
where you have done some of this work or
we can discuss any of your interest uh
for what we have covered in this
question now as we are discussing we
were discussing we learned about time
all we learned about pdb we learned
about different databases and we also
learned about how can we do some of
these manipulations now we can go much
much depth of these and we will be using
these tools throughout the program this
is just an overview so that many of you
get started with these things and
develop these expertise
um throughout the program with the help
of the mentors now going back to the
presentation
so in pie Mall uh what we have done is
uh we have done the installation and
then we have done some basic analysis
then another visualization software that
is there is Chimera and in the next
session we will look at Chimera and we
will look at some of the capabilities of
chimera and where which is utilized for
similarly we will do mutagenesis and we
will do some rmsd calculations where we
will compare two structures and see how
much they are different and then we have
these sessions coming up introduction to
camera informatics
um in the next session then we have
chemistry and protein databases many of
which we have covered but we'll go in
more depth these are the some recorded
sessions also and then we have the
protein structure prediction some of
those key studies like talking
experiments set up what are the
different as we were discussing more the
the more we are being able to mimic it
the more High probability of this to be
accurate and then the drug repurposing
case study that we were discussing will
be discussed as well and then the
advancements of uh transformation using
GPU Computing and deep learning and uh
different uh molecular generation using
deep learning so these are some of the
things that we have it put together and
before I pass it on to sonalika to
discuss about the other aspects I would
request you to join LinkedIn this group
this is a group where uh this has grown
now more to more than twenty thousand
two thousand people so here we
frequently post about the job
opportunities and all of that and in the
omics logistic group on uh on Facebook
we also do the same so if you're on
Facebook LinkedIn please join these
groups and then you'll be low you'll be
able to find job opportunities there as
well as
portal so that's uh that's what I wanted
to cover in today's session and uh I'll
be happy to take the questions that are
there in the chat if uh if uh spanalika
or you can you can let me know about
those questions and in the meantime
um it was great meeting you all for the
first session I hope that this this was
something that was helpful and you
learned something new and uh we will try
to make this more and more interesting
throughout the program thank you so much